nous ne sommes pas dans les cuisines
d'un restaurant mais le chef lui est un
professionnel
au menu ce midi gambas flambées au
pastis betteraves chiot gap here ai'a et
lentilles corail n'ont fait qu'on s'est
vraiment un mélange de couleurs et de
saveurs c'est vraiment la fusion corps
fusion comprenait le mélange de produits
et de cuisine de différents pays
miguel et traiteur à domicile depuis
cinq mois
il cuisine sous l'oeil attentif de
l'hôte et de ses invités
mais le truc de miguel aujourd'hui c'est
un ingrédient surpris donc les griots et
oui des grillons une évidence dans les
pays d'asie du sud-est ou d'afrique
une excentricité en europe pourtant lie
fao considère l'alimentation à base
d'insectes comme une des solutions pour
lutter contre la faim dans le monde
car les insectes sont souvent plus
nutritif que la viande de boeuf par
exemple macérer dans du vinaigre et puis
passez au four
ils sont prêts à être saisi à la poêle
donc là ça va aller très vite en haut du
site
miguel s'est lancé dans la cuisine aux
insectes il y a quelques mois et il
vient même de prendre la présidence de
la fédération française des producteurs
importateurs et distributeurs
d'incessantes roussillon c'est vraiment
que les petits biscuits friands c'est
vraiment super
serge van damme on mange comme ça
franchement ces bois posée sur un toast
de chèvre chaud une alliance presque
naturellement façon ça va faire un petit
peu champêtre
des fois le chèvre il est employé dans
des salades
quand l'ania tout comme ça et puis bon
bah vu que le grillon lui il considéré
donc ça devient sont quand même tranche
au salon l'étrange mais est finalement
bien reçu c'est vrai qu'on est toujours
un peu réticent à manger des insectes
mais cuisiner comme ça c'est vraiment
c'est un petit goût de noisette c'est un
petit goût de c'est vraiment très bon
franchement je pensais pas que c'était
qu'on pouvait manger des insectes
seulement voilà la législation française
ne considère pas les insectes comme des
aliments en france la demande
d'autorisation est en cours à la dgccrf
mais en attendant miguel prend des
précautions ça m'est arrivé de faire
signer une décharge pour faire
comprendre à la personne que moi je lui
fait déguster donc l'insecte à mes
dépens mais qu'il n'y a pas
d'autorisation et ça peut être
problématique quoi au total 1900 espèces
d'insectes serait comestibles de quoi
varier les plaisirs